>> Larry: WELCOME BACK.
VERY EXCITING RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING A NEW
SEGMENT ON TONIGHT'S SHOW THAT
COMBINES TWO OF MY GREATEST
PASSIONS, BOOKS AND OUTER SPACE.
>> WELCOME TO L-DUB'S BOOK CLUB
IN SPACE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: WELCOME.
WELCOME TO L-DUB'S BOOK CLUB IN
SPACE.
NOW, I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THIS IS A NORMAL BOOK CLUB
SEGMENT THAT WE ARE STARTING
TONIGHT THAT JUST HAPPENS TO BE
SET IN SPACE, BECAUSE LIKE I
SAID, I LOVE SPACE AND WE HAD
THE BUDGET FOR IT.
AND IT'S JUST HAPPENS TO BE A
FORTUNATE COINCIDENCE THAT OUR
FIRST GUEST IS LEGENDARY
ASTRONAUT AND ONE OF MY
CHILDHOOD HEROES, BUZZ ALDRIN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: OKAY.
LOOK.
SO, BUZZ, YOU HAVE WRITTEN A
BOOK CALLED "WELCOME TO MARS",
RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, YES.
>> Larry: GREAT.
AND THAT IS INTENDED TO GET KIDS
EXCITED ABOUT SPACE TRAVEL.
IN FACT, HOLD ON A SECOND.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE A
FLY BY OF YOUR BOOK.
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
OH, THERE IT GOES, THERE IT
GOES.
THERE GOES THE BOOK.
>> GET IT!
>> WAY.
>> WHERE DID IT GO?
>> Larry: THERE IT IS.
OKAY.
SO THAT A IS YOUR BOOK.  SO LET
ME ASK YOU.
SO WHAT -- BUZZ, WHAT IS YOUR
BOOK ABOUT, BASICALLY?  WHAT ARE
YOU TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WITH
YOUR BOOK?
>> WELL, IT IS ABOUT MARS.
>> Larry: YEAH.
>> IT IS ABOUT INSPIRING KIDS
FOR THE FUTURE.
>> Larry: FOR THE FUTURE.
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES WHO
WILL BE HELPING TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
>> Larry: SURE.
>> AND MAYBE GOING ALONG AND I
WANT TO WELCOME THEM WHEN THEY
GET THERE.
TO MARS
>> Larry: THAT WOULD BE
AWESOME IF YOU ARE THERE TO
WELCOME THE KIDS.
>> THAT WOULD BE THE MOST
AWESOME THING EVER.
SO WHY DO THEY NEED TO BE
EXCITED ABOUT SPACE?  DO YOU
THINK PEOPLE AREN'T EXCITED
ABOUT SPACE ANYMORE?  THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
>> AH, IT IS HO-HUM
>> HO-HUM.
>> NOTHING TO DO.
>> WE CAN'T EVEN FLY IN OUR OWN
SPACECRAFTS.
WE HAVE TO PAY THE RUSSIANS TO
GET THERE.
>> Larry: WE HAVE THE TESLA
GUYS MAKING THEM AND THE VIRGIN
FLIGHT GUYS MAKING THEM.
IT IS HARD FOR NASA TO GET
FUNDING.
WHY DO YOU THINK THE GOVERNMENT
IS SO DOWN ON NASA?  WHY DO THEY
HAVE TO HATE ON NASA?  WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THAT?
>> THE PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR
ENTHUSIASM.
>> Larry: REALLY?
>> AND THE PEOPLE VOTE FOR THE
PEOPLE IN CONGRESS.
>> Larry: RIGHT.
>> RIGHT? YOU ARE BEGINNING TO
GET THOUSAND WORKS?
>> TO GET HOW THIS WORKS?
>> AND THE PEOPLE VOTE FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO GIVE THEM THE MONEY.
>> Larry: PEOPLE VOTE FOR THE
>> SO THERE IS NO MONEY LEFT.
>> Larry: NO MONEY LEFT.
SO THAT'S WHY -- WHEN I WAS A
KID PEOPLE WERE SO EXCITED.  TO
ME THERE WAS NOTHING MORE
EXCITING THAN THE SPACE RACE.
OKAY.
I WANT TO ASK YOU, YOU ARE AN
EXPERT ON THIS, NO, THE SPACE
RACE, THERE IS IS NOTHING MORE
EXCITING THAN THAT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS MORE
EXCITING -- OH, THE BOOK WENT BY
AGAIN.
>> WHERE DID IT GO?
>> Larry: WAIT A SECOND.
I THINK IT IS WITHIN REACH.
THERE'S A BREACH IN HERE
WAIT A SECOND.
OH.
>> OH.
>>
>> Larry: WE GOT A COPY OF
YOUR BOOK.
>> YOU GRAB THINGS ALL THE TIME?
>> Larry: YES, I BET YOU DO
TOO.
>> NO.
I THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO BE IN A
CORN FIELD.
ON A TREADMILL.
>> IN NEW JERSEY -- A NEW JERSEY
CORN FIELD.
>> Larry: DON'T GIVE AWAY OUR
SECRETS, BUZZ!  THERE IS NO
TREADMILL.
OKAY.
HERE IS WHAT I WANT TO ASK YOU.
>> SPEAKING OF SECRETS, DO YOU
BELIEVE IN EXTRATERRESTRIAL
LIFE, DID YOU GUYS SEE ANYTHING
ON THE MOON?  KEEP IT 100.
>> NEIL HAD THE CAMERA MOST OF
THE TIME.
AND YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT HIS
PICTURE.
HE TOOK A GOOD PICTURE OF ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT MADE IT SO FAMOUS?
>> Larry: WHAT IS THAT?
>> LOCATION, LOCATION, LOCATION.
>> Larry: DO YOU THINK THERE
IS LIFE ON MARS?  DO YOU THINK
WE WILL FIND INTELLIGENT LIFE ON
MARS?
>> THERE WILL BE.
THEN.
OF COURSE WHEN I GET THEM THERE
WITH MY SPACECRAFT.
>> Larry: WHEN DO YOU THINK WE
WILL FIND INTELLIGENT LIFE ON
EARTH?
>> WE HAVE GOT TO LOOK A LONG
TIME.
YOU KNOW, I WENT DOWN TO THE
"TITANIC".
>> Larry: YOU WENT TO THE
TITANIC?
>> YES, DEEP.
>> Larry: REALLY?
>> YEAH.
I AM A DEEP THINKER.
>> Larry: YES.
YOU WENT TO THE DEEPEST PART OF
SPACE AND THE DEEPEST PARTS OF
THE EARTH.
WHAT WAS MORE EXCITING DEEP
SPACE TRAVEL OR DEEP-SEA TRAVEL?
WHAT WAS MORE EXCITING.
>> WELL.
>> Larry: OR MORE DANGEROUS?
>> MAN, I WISH I BROUGHT A SLIDE
WITH ME BECAUSE I HAVE A SLIDE
WHERE I AM RIDING ON A WHALE
SHARK.
>> Larry: REALLY?
>> YES.
>> A WHALE SHARK.
>> Larry: THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
YOU ARE THE MOST INTERESTING MAN
IN THE WORLD!  RIGHT HERE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: OKAY.
THE BOOK IS BUZZ ALDRIN,
"WELCOME TO MARS".
GET YOUR ASS TO MARS.
THIS IS L-DUB'S BOOK CLUB IN
SPACE, SPACE, SPACE!  WE WILL BE
00:05:25,367 --> 00:00:00,000
RIGHT BACK, EVERYONE!